so the uh sag after strike looks like
it's going to last a little bit longer
apologies if there's any loud noises
there's roofers working on the house so
it seems like the big hangup here is AI
now on the one hand this is slightly
surprising given that the
amtp basically conceded pretty much
everything to the writer Guild including
AI why aren't they doing that here
except if you stop and think about it it
does make a certain amount of sense
because AI are at least techniques that
would be greatly assisted by AI have
already been in use in the case of
actors the daging the bringing back of
deceased actors this is stuff they've
already been making use of that they
might lose or at least lose the ability
to do as freely AI writing was largely
theoretical at this point and while I
don't doubt the amtp wants to do more
with AI and actors than they have up to
this point I think they're hardlining it
because they've already seen some
returns in using it or stuff very
similar to it